A few minutes ago the hearing for the formulation
of organized crime charges in the Purga case ended.
The proceeding was carried out all night and
early in the morning and in her presentation,
Attorney General Diana Salazar identified as the leader of the
criminal group the former Christian social assemblyman Pablo Montes,
who managed the Guayas court with the planning of its
former president Fabiola Galardo and Judge Johan Marfetán.
The 3 were identified as perpetrators of the crime.
The prosecutor asked the judge to remand the 12 detainees,
although she indicated that Magistrate Reinaldo Ceballos
would be placed under house arrest for being over 65 years old.
The central element against the findings is the
information found on the phone of mayra salazar,
who was a communicator in the guayas court
and is now in jail for the metastasis case.
The prosecutor also requested that their bank account funds be withheld and
that they be prohibited from selling their assets in the amount of US$3500,000.
At the hearing,
chats and audios of Mayra Salazar were presented with sources,
Galardo and others involved,
showing how they obtained irregular rulings and received favors.
There are also messages with daniel salcedo,
videos of the "los lobos" gang about the murder of fernando villavicencio,
conversations about cases in favor of
alias fito and the attorney general herself.
You also read her name in those chats,
not how they mentioned the state attorney general.
Judge eh javier of the network is now deliberating on the request for
preventive detention and his decision is expected to be known at 4:00 pm.
This is the last minute information here on televistazo.
The community has completed the hearing to bring
charges against 12 defendants in the hurga case.